this is really really funny  you know how it's a very it's like a  point of Pride at some of these rallies  to say you came from really far away it  really just proves your cultist  credentials but they love to say oh I  drove five hours ten hours whatever a  woman explains she drove five hours to  the Trump rally and the interviewer  tries to push on her that the gas prices  were probably crazy and the woman admits  you know their gas prices really weren't  that bad  along with that drive five hours and 20  minutes too bad but I'm sure the gas  prices were bad well uh  you know it wasn't too bad  for what a year and a half there's  they've been saying Joe Biden's gas  prices are destroying the country and  this woman goes you know we've came from  five hours away really we didn't really  pay that much gas prices were actually  quite reasonable